[Applause]
relief in dubai's mission control that
after a journey of 300 million miles
their spacecraft had successfully
slammed on the brakes
and gone into orbit around mars
at the foot of the burj they celebrated
two the first arab mission to another
planet
from a country of fewer than 10 million
people
the space probe called hope will be the
first martian weather satellite
looking for clues to why it's losing its
atmosphere
say if there's a dust storm on mars and
the storms of mars usually
cover the entire planet how much impact
does
do those dust storms have on loss of
hydrogen oxygen therefore
client uh loss of the atmosphere these
are some of the studies that we're
looking into investigating with this
mission
hope is the first of a convoy of
spacecraft reaching mars over the next
week
china's tianwen one has already sent
back a photo
and will land a rover to study the soil
but the most ambitious mission is nasa's
perseverance
a landing that could be directed by
hollywood will put a rover on the
surface
and later engineers will attempt the
first powered flight on another planet
new mean feet and the thin atmosphere
there is no
end to our fascination with mars
throughout science fiction there have
been
races of aliens you know some friendly
some less friendly
uh you know we've in in science fiction
we've sent people to grow potatoes on
mars
things like that now though actually we
can find out
we can find out could we grow potatoes
on mars
could we inhabit mars could we colonize
mars would we want to colonize mars i'm
not certain that we
we would or we should but we want to
find
out more about mars we want to find out
the real stuff
not the stuff that people make up mars
was once a watery world
but below it's now barren surface ice
could remain
and with it at least the signs of
ancient microbial life
our closest planetary neighbour still
has plenty of mystery
thomas more sky news